hey at seven and I just finished
recording videos for today and I have a
massive headache that's Wednesday usual
eyes I film on Wednesdays answer
questions I talk about things I'm
passionate about and sometimes I just
pour so much into it that just fries me
I finish the videos and it's like I just
need to exhale and get a massive
headache as a result so today my cure is
going to be going to my local to
Morton's and getting a nice cappuccino
which is a kind of like a Frappuccino
for those of the American audience you
don't know what two morons is all about
usually when I'm answering the videos
it's just answering questions and a lot
of times that's off the cuff and super
fast but sometimes the questions are
deep and makes me think and becomes a
longer video and so I loud I just pour
myself into it I hope you guys find
things that you're so passionate about
that you pour your heart into when and
if you have a recipe what you do to get
over headache after you've poured
yourself into a project I let me know
I'm on my way to tim hortons I'm in the
stairwell I don't really like taking the
elevator when I can avoid it I'm on the
seventeenth floor so it's a bit of a
walk and you guys you guys are joining
me and my walk so anyway I hope you guys
like the videos that are going to come
out soon I do this for you I got a
headache for you guys and if you do like
the videos let me know what you think
and again in the comments let me know
how you handle your headaches because I
need a solution so thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you soon